I decided to come to Carnegie Mellon
because it offered so much in the way of
teaching opportunities learning by doing
is a proven technique for getting
students to understand material at a
deeper level and I was committed to that
I had taught before in other
environments and this was clearly the
place that was the best match in
software engineering learning by doing
is an unequaled way for students to
learn they get practice in the actual
skills of the domain as well as coming
up with the concepts and the
methodologies that they can take back to
their organization
similarly in software management the
students grapple with these questions
and and methodologies in their teamwork
and we often find that they take back to
their workplace the same week that they
learn a new skill and apply it so
students really love the grounded way
that we teach with learning by doing I
had a 30 year career in industry and
I've brought that knowledge with me to
campus and teach courses that involve
contextual design as well as my research
involving a lot of contextual design
work I felt that I was able to learn a
lot from her experiences and every time
she got out to teach her to lead a class
discussion she would draw from that
personal experience but when we would
kind of have a reality check to see that
you know this material is not just some
saying that we're gonna learn and then
throw away but it's actually something
that we would use in the real world and
so it has all of these real-world
applications the idea is for the
students to succeed we want them to
learn before it's time for the grades to
come and so they are actively involved
with faculty all